[Music]
check
the final venue of the summer for the
native voices traveling exhibition was
the checkasaw nation in oklahoma
we're glad to have representatives of
the national library of medicine join us
for this celebration
it's truly a privilege that the
chickasaw nation is able to host
a comprehensive exhibit and promote
awareness of the practices that the
native people in this country
have held closely for centuries
[Music]
the exhibition was installed at the
artesian gallery and studios in sulfur
oklahoma
the artesian is a working studio where
artists from the chickasaw nation paint
sculpt and weave in this venue
artwork from the local community
complements the native voices exhibition
the name of my business is mahoda
handwovens and that is my great
great great grandmother who was in
mississippi and came at the time of
removal
to indian territory so that is also
coming this full circle
bringing that back and trying to get my
community
to carry on something that i've loved
for many years and tried to establish
at every stop on the tour communities
are encouraged to augment the native
voices exhibition
by showcasing their own art and
artifacts or hosting it during powwows
or other community celebrations
i think that as native people we're
trying to look
at the things that we used to do that
helped us to be healthy
and trying to incorporate those
practices back into our lives
i think that this gives a really unique
opportunity for people to be able to
hear voices
that have not been heard and so to me
that's what the library
of medicine has done for us as citizens
of this
great country they've captured those
stories and
if i could say to dr lindberg again
thank you
you